[Music]
I'm glad y'all here and I will be
showing you one of my games played
actually 10 years ago in my first u.s.
championship and this tournament is very
memorable because it was the first time
I played in the tournament and in fact I
was very close to win it in the last
round I was playing Grandmaster shovel
off in a in a very complicated game in
fact I was 2 pounds up and if I would
have won that game I would have win
clear first in my first attempt so but
this is a different game played in
around 8:00 and it was a very important
victory and I became the leader of the
tournament after winning this game so I
like you to be focused everyone and you
know participate and I'll be asking many
questions here so my opponent is a very
experienced player is Igor fake boy go
ego for Eagle and he also played you
know he's from Russia and he played some
very very top grandmasters so a very
experienced opponent
so I played d4 I'm playing with the
white pieces Knight f6 c4g 693 Bishop g7
are you familiar with which opening is
this please raise your hand if you know
the opening which opening you think this
is ok so few of you good
so this opening is called ok not quite
not quite yes Kings Indian defense ok so
remember when black plays in this
position Bishop g7 this is Kings Indian
defense if somebody asks you a question
here and say what's the name of this
opening what's the correct answer here
no no no no no let's see do you know
what's the correct answer if somebody
asks you let's say if say hey what
opening you think this is what opening
black is playing here see at this point
it's not decided yet you have to wait
one more move okay it's undecided which
opening this is okay so here actually
you cannot answer yet because you know
you don't know which opening is gonna be
because he can play Bishop g7 which he
did my opponent and this is again
remember everybody Kings Indian defense
one of the most popular openings and
played by Kasparov one of the you know
the best King's Indian player known in
history of chess is Garry Kasparov so he
played this opening and he has some very
nice wins with black but also if he
apologized and played Bishop d7 then he
plays d5 do you know this opening aha
this isn't this is now grünfeld this is
another popular opening not as popular
but still very popular in fact today in
the candidates tournament I don't know
if you're following this very big
tournament there were two games played
in this opening so one was Magnus
Carlsen playing as black played the
groom felt another one was Galvan
playing against Fiddler's so nowadays
it's a very popular opening in fact the
top players they use this opening a lot
kronfeld offense but I did some videos
also on a broom fold so if you you can
find these videos on the YouTube channel
and see there were some games I showed
on the grünfeld but this was Kings
Indian defense he played so castles a
Knight f3 Castle Bishop g5 I played now
when I play this Bishop g5 this is
called Smith's loft Petrossian system
okay this is a very rare system I mean
the most popular move here is the you
know before you can play and this will
be the classical Kings Indian defense
kind of game so e5 castle but this is
basically lots of theory and usually
white is under attack but he is winning
on a queen side but you know sometimes
he gets checkmated
it's a very complex position here you
get I also played this way too sometimes
but my main specialty I play Bishop g5 I
played this move for many many years and
have lots of experience playing this
Smith Slav Petrossian system so now
Bishop g5
he played d6 and the point is to
remember you don't play efore here
because if you were gonna play before
then you should right away so you play
III now the point is in the King's
Indian this Bishop is very strong by
putting the pawn on the tree you can't
enough restrict this Bishop so this
Bishop is not going to be able to attack
anything right now and now he played
Knight bd7
so you develop the Bishop to e2 here in
this opening you can also play Bishop ut
but it's not very effective because here
Bishop will be blocking your queen and
also against the Ancheta structure
Bishop is not very effective here
because it's you're not gonna be able to
take on g6 and you don't have that much
scope on this diagonal so that's why you
play Bishop e2 now he plays h6 attacking
my bishop and this is a kind of an eye a
common idea here black is trying to win
my dark square bishop by chasing it to
g3 and playing Knight h5 now he's gonna
win my bishop on g3 but what's the
problem with this pawn you think because
yeah if he can just win the bishop
that's but there is something also
negative about what he just did right
can you see what's the problem now by
just this last few moves yes aha open up
the diagonal in fact this diagonal is
now very weak and there are some weak
light squares now and you will see in
this game I will be able to actually in
fact I have a Windows game because of
the weak light squares my play is gonna
be based on that
he's gonna win my dark square bishop but
I'm gonna try to take advantage of his
weak light squares so now in this
position when he plays Knight h5 I
decided I need to make a move here to
force him to capture the bishop on g3
because then I can take back with which
pond H pawn right of course you take
back with h1 but now can you find a move
that will force him to capture Knight to
f3 word aha yes you want to move that
night but which Square which would be
the bed Square D 2 so we gonna ID q
immediately attacking the knight he's
not gonna go back because if he goes
back his whole idea of chief h6 g5 9 h 5
going back he's not gonna go back this
will be very bad because he already
weakened the position and his idea is at
least to get the bishop so he takes
again most of the time
90% of the time you always take from the
side to the center but in this position
especially you take because you open up
the line for the rook ok now I take with
the H pawn now he plays c5 it's a
correct move here because he has bishops
when you have bishops you want to open
the position and that's what he's trying
to do with the move c5
it's an idea but not as strong not a
strong because here I could also
possibly even go Castle queenside if I
put my queen it's definitely in this
position you take without a pun if let's
say I if I already cancelled here in
some point this idea you should consider
if I was already cancelled there then I
would consider that but in this position
definitely taking back with the H pawn
and now pressuring on h6 so now it plays
a good move c5 and the question is what
to do now he's trying to open up the
position and I need to do something I
need to react to this move now so what
do you do I could do that I could do
that but then it's gonna be a couple of
exchanges in the center and every time
we exchange pounds bishops gonna get
stronger and like if I go here he would
take let's say I take back then he goes
here solidifying a little bit his
position and my Knights are kind of away
from the attack my idea to have an
advantage is to try to organize a very
strong attack here but here with an item
b3 my Knights a little bit positionally
I'm not buried that much my chance is
here to try to attack but again what to
do after this move c5 d5 even though
this move might be a little bit hard to
play if you're not so familiar with the
position you because you may think
okay okay so so if c5 you play d5 the
reason it might not be that easy to play
this move because you may think wait a
minute
look at this Bishop now it's very strong
but in fact this Bishop cannot really
move away because he needs to protect
this with pawn that we're putting
pressure on okay yes the bishop looks
strong here but it's just only one piece
and by pushing the pawn on d5 what do we
gain what do we gain space right so now
again we are into his position now right
so remember now when you push the pawn
to d5 when your pawn now crosses the
fifth round here that's already his
territory so you enter that that means
you control more squares now and
restrict his pieces now d5 f5 plate
gaining space and also kind of blocking
this diagonal okay
is six for black well if you play six in
this position a few things possible but
one of the first ideas I can see that
capture once now because the position is
getting a little bit more weak now
and after this move we will have one to
two pieces attack need upon and no
defenders and he cannot defend upon in
one move twice in this position okay so
this could be a problem I think I will
win upon
so that's why he paid f5 now let's see
from here on I want you to find the
moves over this game this is 27 moves in
this game the total so let's see here we
are on a move number 13 here what do you
think I should do here because he's
trying to gain some space maybe even
possibly play a four in some point
uh-huh that's what I played but what is
the main idea behind therefore it's it
blockading his pawns or I have something
else that I'm trying to do with f4 here
attack but that's an idea of course that
would be you know if he can somehow put
the knight on e5 they'd all be good but
now we take that away but there is
something else I have after this move I
have another idea
uh-huh in some point I can take and H
file will be open so this is a very
important idea because then I can try to
take in fact this is what happened in
the game but then if it takes how are we
gonna take back huh okay so we take with
the Japan of course this way we also
under ball the double pond see that were
puns so when you have a chance to run
double so you take that and now I will
try to go Queen c2 and I also have g4
idea so I really have a very strong
attack here if it takes but he didn't
take so he plays Knight f6
which is a normal move and now do you
think I'm ready to attack here what do
you think you think I'm ready to attack
here because remember I know you know I
mentioned a lot of development and
everything but it's very important to
know that sometimes there are exceptions
to that we do but overall you think
white is ready to attack here or he
needs to develop one more piece Queen
that's a very good idea you want to
develop the Queen because with the Queen
it's gonna be much easier to attack we
will have more possibilities now what
square rooting is the best for the Queen
here that you can try to put what square
we have for the Queen in this position
yes
C - absolutely Queen goes to C - and now
I'm also getting ready to castle okay
I'm getting ready to castle here but I
end up not castling in this game because
I didn't have time so again not always
sometimes time it's more important you
can't just have everything so if you
have a good chance for attack you go for
it so now you play the e6
I was just gonna say that you could have
he could have tried to play pawn g4 but
there is a problem with this move I got
Bishop d3 and now f5 is very weak it's
not so clear how to protect this pawn
because I have the Queen and a bishop
attacking it and he I mean you can play
Queen d7 but it looks very very awkward
now castle you could but I mean if you
look at the position I mean I mean this
is not a very good it's not very good
you know now the move he played in a
game it's actually very concrete because
if I don't play precisely against the
move he plays he made up actually better
because he's really opening up the
position here that's what he's trying to
do g4 you could play but it's just a bad
position I mean you're gonna have to go
I don't know if Queen d7 very awkward
now I can just go long castle and
prepare the e4 break if you go ninety
eight then all your pieces are on the
back rank you know they're supposed to
be in the game so it's not a very good
setup in fact I might even have a root
page five here so it's it's not very
good you know he could have maybe also
taken but it's still slightly slightly
better for me so he played a six here
it's a logical move because he wants to
now take and right away attack my pawn
only three because my a three-pound is
weak and my king is in the middle of the
board so the natural thing in this
position would be to try to let's say
castle for example but then it was Queen
e7 and now he's threatening to capture
and the e3 pawn is weak
and this way he will start distracting
me from the attack because I have to
worry about his threats now ok so that's
why I didn't cancel here now let's see
if you can find the best continuation
here for white after which I have a big
advantage here
Ponte c5 correct after this move I have
a very bad one structure very simple if
we just take off the Queen's after board
here right
Lucky's probably winning if the Queen's
come off the board because he has two
bishops much better pawn structure
positionally I'll just be lost here if
the quiz we just take the Queen's after
board here but I'm not gonna exchange
the Queen's here I'm gonna try to open
the position of the King how can I do
that here
not quiet not quiet yes
Bishop d3 he still plays Queenie seven
haha idea correct but timing if you have
the correct idea you have to make sure
that it's the right time also to play it
that's the idea to play g4 here to open
this diagonal here but what do I need to
do first to make sure that diagonal is
really weak yes
captain is six immediately creating a
thread Queen 2x f5 so he has to take
back
he played Bishop e6 now g4 see making is
in the middle of the board so this is a
very dangerous but now I've calculated
I've calculated what's really gonna
happen now and here's I need only one
move I can just if I have time I could
just castle so he can't really attack me
immediately here and when I have a time
I was just call on Castle but now I open
up the position because for example if I
let him play g4 now then he would block
the position so this this Moochie fort
is very important here here he spent a
lot of time maybe more than 30 minutes
because he realized here it's very
dangerous for him let's take a look
white so dangerous the first natural
move would be just to go Queen d7 maybe
to protect twice you can maybe try to do
that but then I just go castle
let's say he goes rook ae8 now I capture
once he captures should be three after
we exchange the bishops
just look at the live scores now see all
the squares are very weak for him and
all I need to do in this position to win
this game is just to deflect this night
from f6 and I have many ways to do that
here I simply can go here then go 95 and
as soon as he takes Queen h7 mate and he
can he can really do anything to create
create contra play here because he's too
busy defending against my threats
so this is what I'm trying to do like
this would be a perfect position if I
can get I would just go rook DF 1 and
then 95 and he can't really do anything
do you see any defense here for black
and he can't exchange Queens also like
he would be excellent for him to
exchange Queens but he can't really do
that here so that's why he spent a lot
of time here let's take a look what's
what's happening if he just captures for
example why he cannot just capture right
now I go take check now can you find a
winning move
yeah that's a good move but I would
prefer a castle actually because that
way I connect my rooks Sirica fun is a
natural move but you also have to forget
don't forget that you know you can still
castle both wolves are winning but this
is just much much more effective because
when when he takes I will take with this
piece and also give him a checkmate from
here or win some more material I mean
win a rock or something after check
takes so you can't just take because we
take take and a very nice full castle so
and if he takes with the pawn the only
other thing he can do in the game the
move in the game actually pretty
interesting and if it takes now here can
you find a best move here
94 I'm not sure because here's Bishop f5
see in this position actually I don't
need to rush here because I already
accomplished my goal of weakening the
diagonal I just need to be a little bit
patient here and make this move because
this way my King is very safe and again
this piece is now coming to the F file
and then I have many ideas such as
Bishop d3 Bishop h7 he cannot take Queen
h7 mate
if he comes king of 7 then Queen g6
check and I win the bishop his king is
really open now he cannot just take upon
and try to defend I have ideas such as
Queen g6 here as well too many threats
but if he thinks I'll just calmly castle
this would be my favorite move here
there are other moves as well but then I
just bring the rook on f1 and all my
pieces are attacking his King here he
has some defenders but it's just it's
not going to be enough to defend it so
he paid them interesting move 97 it's
hard to say whether or not this is the
best one but at least again I have to
think now and try to find something
really strong the point of this move is
he opened the file for the rook and
protected on f5 and he wants to go 95 if
let's say I Castle I allow him to go 95
and he's back in the game now this
position is just about one move that's
why I don't have time to cancel because
he will centralize his Knight and he's
back in the game here I'm still a little
bit better but I can't just try to win
right away so now
what should I do now because you know
his next movie is gonna be 95
you could go night after II yeah but not
quite what I want to do mirror my goal
is to exchange which pieces in this game
live score bishops once you exchange the
lights to bishops then he can't hold a
position anymore too many in weak light
squares absolutely and temple right we
attack so he has to take back Bishop d3
very important move just exchange the
logic of bishops off the board now if he
takes we will reach the position that I
was talking about but I think I will
reach with extra a few temples for white
because I'm already threatening this
check so he's gonna have to go back and
I would just Castle so same exact
position but with a few extra temples
because he went ninety seven and night
of six so just Rock F 195 and game is
over so here he spent time again and
played bishops III can you tell me why
this move is losing why Queen f6 is
losing
don't rush don't rush there are few
options you have but you need to find
the best move 95 is good yes but you
have to calculate yeah because he has
Quimby - for example if he goes back we
just take and we have a very nice work
and winning the Queen I think so
and if it takes on b2
then I could just take
and take here first because now if he
takes my rook I can simply take the
knight on d7 and it's a technically
winning position because not only I have
two minor pieces for the rook but
they're just simply dominating the board
because rooks are not going to be
attacking anything here yet square is
also under control I will simply come up
King you to put the pan on g4 90 for
Bishop even though we don't have Queens
but I I can probably have a mating
attack also with all my Knights
Bishop and Rock so this is winning and
if it takes you go rupee one first and
now threatening the bishop and a ninety
seven fork now what is the only move to
stop these two ideas Bishop f6 now what
do you do it goes here can you see the
winning combination I mean there are
many ways to win but you could go Knight
e4 forst forst win here basically when
pieces like this like cramped and they
just defending they're overloaded okay
are you familiar with overloaded teas
term this is when one piece is doing too
many things defending two things so now
you just need to find a way to deflect
one of the defenders
efore is good I like G for a little bit
better now what is the rockin ago one
square right to go here and now what do
you do now it's clear right the rook is
the overloaded piece I'm sorry the
knight is defending so we take takes
check I'll take the other piece too okay
there are a few other ways to win but
this would be the most concrete way okay
so that's why he cannot play Queen f6
because 95 is just winning the game on
the spot and if he goes Queen is six
what do you do just yet tell me the
bishop takes correct see like this would
be a mistake to go because now he wins
check and then he will probably made me
so you have to be careful you could be
winning but then you just get carried
away make one quick move thinking you're
winning and then suddenly you can never
relax okay
you can only relax when opponent resign
okay because there are many games you're
winning but you're not gonna win at the
end so you have to be made you have to
make sure you're focused so you take he
takes now
aha Queen takes root again this idea
works because of which again overloaded
piece right
the Queen is to overload it is because
defending a seventh Square and defending
the rook so when the piece is overloaded
you always have to look for this ideas
okay so now we go Queen takes sacrifice
the Queen he takes back and now check
goes back take so now we see that he
cannot go Queen f6 the reason yeah
that's why I want to show you all the
possible moves so you know why he
chooses to play Bishop C 3 because this
move looks dangerous to play now Bishop
takes c3 best practical chance because
we saw other moves are just losing and
here at least it could get a little bit
confusing so many things I can do I can
take with a pawn I can take the c3
Bishop I can take their five bishop
usually when you have choices like this
in chess it's possible to make a mistake
because a lot of moves they look good
and then you end up making the move that
it's not the best so this is where it's
common to make a mistake when you have a
choice all the moves so you have few
choices here but what do you think is
the best Bishop takes Bishop AHA
absolutely Bishop takes Bishop because
this move creates a very strong head of
Bishop e6 and now we open up the
diagonal for the Queen but the problem
is what do we do with the check because
we cannot take now with the Queen
because the bishop is hanging see now I
take with the King now my King is also
not very safe but again it's very
concrete by the way he couldn't just go
back if it goes back anywhere he just
gets made it check comes up
check with the rook no that's a mate to
I guess and checkmate King is just too
weak
so that's why he plays Bishop d2 check
uh-huh see this was he was hoping maybe
for something like that because then he
gets a chance to centralize his night
because the pressure from the f5 Bishop
is gone remember I had two pieces
attacking now the pressure his gun he's
kind of I'm still better again but he's
kind of back in the game I mean I take
he takes I go long castle but it's not
the same I mean white is still much
better so I took he takes he has to take
I take with the king now now the threat
is very strong Bishop e6 and it's not so
clear what he can do to stop it
for example if he plays Queen e7 what do
you do looks like he just stopped Bishop
e6 Bishop e6 anyway very strong because
again we see another idea seems like in
this game we see lots of overworked
piece team
ideas here now what is the Queen doing
protecting here and here right by
playing Bishop e6 we sacrifice the
bishop but he cannot take it because of
the main again now he has to come up and
you can just checkmate by checking with
the rock this time he comes up here we a
five mate so he doesn't have he all he
needed someone move to put that night
only five in this game then he's safe
but he just doesn't have time to put
that knight on e5 here okay
now also it looks like he may just play
this move
it looks like you might be able to do
this but why is this move losing
Bishop e6 Shack but then here's King g7
at least for a moment it looks like he
stopped to threats yeah
very good move Queen to a5 simply
threatening to take the pawn that would
be a checkmate so your bishop is in your
rook is in but now you need one more
piece into the game and you bring your
Queen into the game and threat is very
strong he cannot do anything and no
worries about the discovery check
because we take back with the Queen the
Queen wasn't controlling there we would
lose the Queen you could take it but you
just take so that's why he played the
rook f6 defending against Bishop e6 and
opening up some squares for his King to
escape and again here is one more move
here to put a night on a fate he will be
safe let's say I just tried to do
something else he puts a knight on a
fade it's not gonna be easy to win now
now white is bidding winning by force
here how
now you just need to calculate you have
a win here but you need to calculate
Bishop e6 check very good sacrificing
the bishop he has to take he cannot go
here because at the check he will lose
his Queen he cannot go here because he
will just get mated check with the Queen
has to go here
check with the Queen and check with the
rock cannot take the bishop and we make
them so he has to play group takes his
six which he did now we need a follow-up
we nee the precise follow-up here when
you sacrifice a piece you have to
calculate because if you don't have a
checkmate then you win Queen eight seven
correct King f8 see rushing rushing and
that's an inaccuracy right there you're
letting him get the night in you're
letting him get the night in the rookin
you have to make sure you check that way
his pieces don't come correct
Queen h8 check he cannot go here why
checkmate say King is in the box so he
has to come here now now don't rush
again don't rush again we checked this
way he gets there you know rook h7 check
he goes here again don't rush there are
a few ways you can play here but you
need to find the best move see if you go
Queen check most natural move and then
it goes here not as clear okay
my goal is to make sure his pieces
remain the way they are not to let them
come in and block the tracks
it's a possible move that's probably
also winning that's probably winning
also something a little bit better a
little bit better because I'm not really
interested in winning material here I
have a force made here but there is a
square that is occupied right now and I
want to make sure that I have that
square for my Queen which square I'm
talking about
h7
yes because his King isn't gonna go on
the lights course so I want to have that
square available for my queen rook g7
check King f5
now we could do Queen but now let's look
at the position and see if we have a
piece that it's ready to come in into
the game okay fast it's good my King is
here because if the King was only one I
couldn't use it so here I go check you
resign here let's see why he's getting
made it if he goes here mate in one
Queen h3 if he goes here mate in to
several mate in twos
double check takes rook a4 mate and if
he goes now here you will see why I
played room g7 now so I can use the
square for my queen they were probably
other ways to win also but this is just
the most precise check he comes here
queen fi checkmate so he resigned here
so he resigned after I played rook F 1
because he's gonna get checkmated so as
you can see in this game he didn't get
to move his rook Queen see this pieces
never came into the game sometimes there
are games like this where you just don't
have time to get your pieces out and
that's usually not very good so and even
though he is he's got a extra piece on
the board but he cannot really do
anything because the position of the
King is very weak
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]